نظام التجنيد العسكري كابوس متواصل يلاحق
الشباب الروس رغم اعلان الرئيس الروسي
ووزير الدفاع الانتهاء من تعبئه نحو
300,000 جندي جديد
فالعديد من الروس الذين تنطبق عليهم
مواصفات المقاتل اي السنه واللياقه
الجسديه المطلوبه لا يزالون مختبئين وسط
مخاوف من ارسالهم للقتال وما قالوا انه
الموت في حرب فاشله الهاربون غيروا اماكن
سكنهم وبعضهم متى يقيموا في خيم بالغابات
وفق واشنطن بوست فيما الاختارات متراكمه
على ابواب منازلهم خوفا من التعرض لكماءنا
والاضطرار لتسلم استدعاءاتنا والتوقيع
عليها كما حصل مع اقربائها
لا سيما ان الاعلان عن انتهاء التعبئه لم
يترافق مع مرسوم قانون رسميا ينهي حمله
التجنيد الاجباريه
التجنيد جزء من حمله اجراءات شنتها روسيا
منذ بدا عمليتها في اوكرانيا واخرها
اعتزام الرئيس الروسي تجريد مواطنين من
جوازات سفرهم الروسيه في حال انتقادهم
للحربه صحف غربيه اكدت اقتراح فتن تغييرات
على مشروع قانون يستهدف المواطنين غير
المولودين في روسيا والذين حصلوا على
جوازات السفر الروسيه اثناء الحرب مضيفه
ان المقترحه تم تمريره وهنا المقصود
الاوكرانيون الذين اجبروا او لم يكن لديهم
خيار لتغيير جنسيتها بسبب التهديدات
الروسيه بعد دخول مدنها وفقه صحيفه كيف